حسنًا ، لنتحدث عن إيران ، فإن مجموعة العشرين
تتصدى أيضًا لخطر
الأسلحة النووية الإيرانية هذا الأسبوع قبل
استئناف المفاوضات حول الاتفاق النووي
في فيينا ، فهل نحن مستعدون
لزيادة الضغط على إيران
لإعادتهم إلى طاولة المفاوضات ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فماذا يفعل؟
هذا الضغط يبدو
جيدًا شيئين أولهما التقى الرئيس بايدن
أه هنا في أم في روما أه
مع ألمانيا أه فرنسيته
ونظرائه البريطانيين أه نحن
في خطى مطلقة أه معًا على أه
كيف نقترب من التحدي
المتمثل في الوصول إلى إيران  العودة للامتثال
للاتفاق النووي أه وأه
وهذا جديد لأننا كنا في
خلاف في السنوات الأخيرة حول ذلك عندما
انسحبت الولايات المتحدة من
الاتفاقية ، لذلك هناك شيئان ما
زلنا نعتقد أن الدبلوماسية
هي أفضل طريقة  أه للتعامل مع
التحديات التهديد الذي يمثله
أه البرنامج النووي الإيراني على وجه
الخصوص وللأسف الخطوات
التي تم اتخاذها
منذ الانسحاب وفي الآونة الأخيرة  من
أجل زيادة خطورة هذا البرنامج أه
لا تزال هناك نافذة يمكن
من خلالها لإيران أن تعود إلى
المحادثات
ويمكننا أن نعود إلى الامتثال المتبادل
للاتفاقية
وستكون هذه أفضل نتيجة لكن
الأمر يعتمد حقًا على ما إذا كانت إيران
جادة في فعل ذلك.  أن جميع
بلداننا التي تعمل بالمناسبة مع
روسيا والصين
تؤمن إيمانًا راسخًا بأن هذا سيكون
أفضل طريق للمضي قدمًا ،
لكننا لا نعرف حتى الآن ما إذا كانت إيران مستعدة
للعودة والمشاركة بطريقة هادفة والعودة إلى
الامتثال
إذا  إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك ،
فإننا نبحث معًا
في جميع الخيارات اللازمة للتعامل
مع هذه المشكلة